with 35 seconds to go  [Applause]  Irving backs it out 14 to shoot 26  seconds to play knits are down by one  Irving step-back three to the lead  [Applause]  Kairi spot I've seen it in Cleveland  people have seen it in Boston Brooklyn  Nets need to understand when Kyrie wants  a key shot he goes to that right side of  the floor that right side when he works  he pulls it back he takes his time let  me get to my spot we've seen this he's  hit some big shot from this exact angle  same thing work them get a step back  that is Kyrie sweet spot for three and  RJ parent hasn't yet been around long  enough to wash that and here's the first  one though where it began  the crossover nice seeds jump shot here  but this second one in the country had  an opportunity as you mentioned he's got  an open right lane where he could've  drove but instead Richard you said it  gets to his spot stairs down there  makes it look as smooth as it comes but